vous connaissez tous cette sensation qui
fait qu'on arrive dans une pièce et puis
qu'on a complètement oublié pour qu'on
voulait y aller
un autre exemple de cette sensation
c'est lorsqu'on vous donne un numéro de
téléphone à l'oral et que vous devez le
retenir
tenez essayé de retenir celui là 06 18
75 20 9 06 18 75 9
ok je suis maintenant prêt à parier que
si je plaçais un petit micro dans
chacune de vos têtes
on pourra entendre comme une étrange
litanie il est aujourd'hui consensus
scientifique pour parler d'un côté de
mémoire à court terme et de l'autre de
mémoire à long terme à la mémoire à
court terme
c'est un petit peu comme une boîte dans
laquelle on peut mettre que cette
information en moyenne et dès qu'on en
rajoute une de trop bas la trappe
s'ouvre et y en a une qui s'en va
pourquoi parce que ces informations ne
servent qu'à ce que nous sommes en train
de faire oui pour ça c'est bien beau
mais nous quand on veut mémoriser des
choses pour notre culture générale pour
notre travail ou même pour nos études
comment faire et bien ce soir j'aimerais
vous proposer de passer par trois étapes
simples pour apprendre à mémoriser à
long terme et la première c'est
comprendre lorsque nous comprenons
quelque chose c'est un petit peu comme
un signal pour le cerveau qui lui
indique qui peut maintenant mémoriser
plus facilement l'information
d'ailleurs vous avez tous pu comprendre
ce qu'est la mémoire à court terme
lorsque je vous l'expliquais tout à
l'heure avec l'image de la boîte mais
vous avez compris ça exactement de la
même manière que vous avez compris ce
que vous avez pu lire dans votre journal
ce matin ou sur internet cet après midi
mais vous le savez tous comprendre ne
suffit pas pour mémoriser à long terme
il faut passer à la deuxième étape
balisé lorsque nous souhaitons trouver
un souvenir donc une information qui
n'est pas encore apprise par coeur
et bien notre cerveau se replacent
automatiquement dans le contexte il
cherche un repère un panneau qui va
finalement lui indiquer l'endroit où il
a rangé l'information je vois par
exemple beaucoup d'étudiants qui arrive
devant leurs copies d'examen et qui sont
capables de me dire exactement l'endroit
sur leur cahier où était écrit ce qu'ils
avaient à mémoriser
en faisant cela le cerveau peut
distinguer une information d'une autre
et il peut ainsi se repérer dans le
temps
oui mais seulement parfois les contextes
les repères sont tellement proches les
uns des autres qu'il devient très
difficile pour le cerveau de s'y
retrouver
j'ai pour cela un petit exemple
j'aimerais que vous participiez je vous
demander de répondre à une question à
main levée qui parmi vous se sent
capable de me dire ce qu'il a pu manger
avant-hier midi ceux qui s'en rappellent
lever la main s'il vous plaît donc de la
douchy j'en vois kw à 5 6 qui lève la
main un peu plus mais ça fait pas
beaucoup et c'est normal pourquoi parce
que tous les midis se ressemblent et
qu'il est très difficile pour le cerveau
de distinguer un midi d'un autre bon
évidemment si vous avez été au
restaurant c est fait la fête
s'ils avaient fait quelque chose d'un
petit peu particuliers souhaitaient voir
votre frère ou que sais-je
eh bien là vous allez retrouver
l'information mais il ya quelque chose
aussi c'est que lorsque vous avez un
cours une conférence à retenir c'est un
petit peu le même principe que
avant-hier 12h01
on ne retrouve plus exactement où on a
rangé les différentes informations que
le conférencier a dit eh bien pour
pallier à ça je vous propose de passer à
une prochaine étape qui s'appelle
visualiser
visualisez qu'est ce que la
visualisation et bien c'est une capacité
naturelle que nous avons tous à pouvoir
nous représenter des images en trois
dimensions plus ou moins animée bon ça
c'est la théorie mais moi vous savez
j'aime beaucoup la pratique donc
j'aimerais vous inviter tous ce soir
avoue m confortablement dans votre siège
voilà les deux pieds au sol a fermé les
yeux et la reste est maintenant très
attentif à ce que je vais vous demander
de voir parce qu'il s'agit de voir s'il
s'agit pas seulement d'écouter voyez
bien les images que je vais vous dire je
vous demander de vous visualisez chez
vous dans votre chambre vous voyez votre
vie vous voyez vos mains
représentez-vous bien dans la pièce
voyez vous dans cette pièce c'est très
important et juste à côté sur votre lit
vous voyez lauriers là il ya des
saucisses cuites sur votre oreiller
vous pouvez voir qu'il ya comme le tissu
qui est en train d'être imbibé par
l'huile des saucisses vous allez mettre
des jours à nettoyer et juste à côté
regarde et je vois le coupable c'est un
pompier de paris
et oui il est là assis sur votre lit
approchez-vous un peu lui il vous tend
une bouteille une bouteille de vin
prenez là vous pouvez sentir dans vos
mains et c'est très important sentais
bien
la fraîcheur de cette bouteille de vin
regardez maintenant à l'intérieur de
cette bouteille de vin il ya 1,9 alors
évidemment vous allez essayer de le
faire sortir
retournez la bouteille essayez de taper
contre le fond de la bouteille alesi
tapez tapez ouvrage est dans le vide
c'est ok voilà elle vit et regardez là
le love sort et il vient taper contre
une boîte en carton
cette boîte en carton s'ouvre à la volée
et là vous voyez sept nains les sept
nains de blanche neige et les sept nains
ils sont juste à côté de vous et
cherchent tous à comprendre quelque
chose sénat ils cherchent tous à
comprendre quelque chose
et vous aussi essayer de comprendre ce
qu'ils regardent au plafond essayer de
comprendre
ils sont en train de regarder un panneau
oui un panneau un panneau au plafond et
regardez bien un panneau de
signalisation et juste au centre de ce
panneau vous pouvez voir une image et
cette image
vous même assis dans cette salle en
train de visualiser un petit peu comme
si quelqu'un vous avez pris en photo et
à ce moment là
regardez bien cette image regardez-la
attentivement parce qu'elle est en train
de tomber un petit peu comme une feuille
morte elle vient se poser sur la tête de
votre meilleure amie qui était juste à
côté vous l'aviez pas encore au but
approchez-vous un petit peu de votre
meilleur ami là vous avez très envie de
lui réexplique et la conférence allez-y
réexpliqué lui les choses voyez-vous en
train de faire de grands gestes de lui
réexpliquer tous les techniques de ce
soir et quand ce sera fait je vous
invite et progressivement à revenir dans
l'ici et maintenant et à rouvrir
doucement les yeux ont conservé en
mémoire tout ce qui vient de se passer
si vous avez eu du mal tout à l'heure à
vous rappeler les numéros qui était
inscrit sur le diaporama
c'est normal parce que c'est un faux
elle était dans votre mémoire à court
terme et chercher à les répéter pour que
ça rentre
mais avec la méthode que nous venons de
faire vous venez de les faire passer
directement dans votre mémoire à long
terme et je sais que vous êtes des gens
vient alors vous voulez des preuves pas
vrai ben ouais ok replacer vous au début
de l'histoire est regardée sur
l'oreiller vous allez voir il ya quelque
chose ce sont des sauts des saucisses
exactement saw 6 pour le numéro 06
c'est ça on enchaîne juste à côté il y
avait qu il y avait un
un pompier pour le numéro effectivement
c'est le numéro qu'on appelle en cas
d'urgence et juste à côté qu'est ce qui
se passe
n'en attendez attendez c'est un pompier
particulier c'est un pompier 2 ouais
donc paris pour le numéro numéro
départementale 75 et juste après
qu'est-ce qui se passe ils vous donnent
la bouteille de vin exactement la
bouteille de vin pour le numéro tout à
fait
et y'a quoi dedans il y à 1 pour le
numéro pour le chiffre 9 du mans oui
c'est ça exactement
bravo et vous pourrez essayer de vous
rappeler de ce numéro plus tard pour
voir comment il est rentré dans votre
mémoire par exemple demain la semaine
prochaine et si vous avez bien
visualiser il y sera encore une bonne
visualisation dure en moyenne de
quelques jours toute votre vie en fait
ça va dépendre du nombre de fois vous
allez l'actualiser cette méthode est
aussi utilisée depuis la grèce antique
c'est dire le depuis le temps qu'elle
est utilisée et elle est aujourd'hui
utilisée encore dans les championnats du
monde de mémoire quand il y à des
personnes qui sont capables de mémoriser
des centaines de chiffres ou de mots à
la suite
toutefois ces connaissances ne
rejoignent pas vos connaissances
générales du monde
je vais vous poser une petite question
et là vous répondez tous encore dans
quelle ville sommes venus aujourd'hui
exactement orléans et vous n'avez pas
réfléchi pour accéder à cette
information pourquoi parce qu'elle fait
partie de vos connaissances générales du
monde ça vient spontanément par contre
les images qu'on a visualisé la va
falloir les retrouver refaire l'histoire
voyez le problème du coup je vous invite
à passer à la troisième étape réexpliqué
lorsque nous ré expliquons les choses
nous permettons aux cerveaux de faire du
lien entre les anciennes connaissances
et les nouvelles je vois par exemple
beaucoup d'étudiants qui arrive devant
leurs copies d'examen encore une fois et
qui ont bien compris le recours pas de
soucis un chez eux ils pouvaient le
répéter par contre une fois qu'ils sont
devant leur copie il n'arrive plus à
leur expliquer le fait de leur expliquer
en amont permet trois choses 1 de
transformer une information qui est
vague en mots qu'on crée deux de
repartir de la base du sujet et de
vérifier que tout a été bien acquis
pourquoi parce que quand vous ré
expliquer les choses à quelqu'un et ben
si vous repartez pas de la base du sujet
comment vous voulez que la personne et
vous suivent donc là vous allez vérifier
si vous avez bien tout acquis et enfin 3
ça va permettre de ré agencer les
informations parce que parfois certaines
vont plus facilement ensemble et ça
l'apprentissage ok maintenant on a fait
un petit peu de théorie un petit peu de
pratique mais je présente ses points
clés comme ça il faudrait les essayer
bah ouais donc on y va mettons par
exemple ce soir que vous vouliez
mémoriser cette conférence dans l'ordre
ouais
eh ben c'est parti les riches sont les
points-clés premier point est ce que
vous avez pu comprendre cette conférence
certainement oui il ya eu des exemples
pratiques mais il ya eu des choses
concrètes dans l'ensemble et je l'espère
pour vous ça a dû être compris ok
deuxième point avez-vous pu baliser
cette conférence et bien normalement oui
on a fait de la visualisation tous
ensemble et on a normalement mis tous
les points clés nécessaires pour se
rappeler les grandes lignes de cette
conférence mais bon encore une fois vous
êtes des gens bien alors il faut qu'on
vérifie c'est vrai alors c'est parti on
vérifié replacer vous à la suite de
l'histoire vous voyez il y a eu l'offre
qui a roulé il a roulé il a tapé contre
1 une à carton le carton au début
c'était pour vous expliquer quoi déjà la
mémoire à à court terme c'est ça et les
cartons il ya qui sort les sept nains
sept nains pour cette information en
moyenne de la mémoire à court terme et
on enchaînait ensuite les sept nains et
cherche à faire quoi il chercha à
comprendre c'est ça les regarde le
plafond il cherche à comprendre la
première étape pour mémoriser et cherche
la comprendre il regarde il voit quoi
ils voient un panneau un panneau pour
baliser la deuxième étape pour mémoriser
et ensuite ils regardent enfin ce même
vous vous regardez au centre du panneau
et là vous voyez une image de vous même
en train de visualiser c'est ça la
troisième étape ou du moins l'étape qui
permet de créer des repères et enfin la
dernière étape
c'est lorsqu'il ya votre meilleur ami et
que vous lui réexplique et la conférence
tout à fait bravo à ses pairs
on passe maintenant du coup à la fin de
cette conférence
bah oui c'est déjà la fin on s'amuse
bien juste avant que m
effectivement quand vous avez pu mettre
des panneaux vous avez pu comprendre il
reste un dernier point il reste à ré
expliquer les choses et ça vous ne
l'avez pas encore fait mais quand vous
allez le faire
ça ressemblera un petit peu à quelque
chose comme ça l'imaginé là il ya votre
collègue bon c'est la conférence ce soir
ça a parlé de vous allez chercher un peu
là c'est normal
et à ce moment là regardez bien dans
votre tête vous allez voir la première
image qui est celle du carton avec les
sept nains donc vous revenez oui ça
parlait de mémoire à court terme oui
parce qu'il ya aussi une mémoire à long
terme et à courte je passe tu savais il
ya aussi cette information dedans
moyenne pennec tout ça et vous enchaînez
comme ça jusqu'à ne plus avoir besoin
des images et lorsque cette conférence
vous pourrez en parler avec vos propres
mots aussi bien que le orléans de tout à
l'heure vous voyez aussi facilement
aussi fluide mans et bien ça voudra dire
qu'elle a rejoint vos connaissances
générales du monde
il suffira ensuite de l'actualiser de
temps en temps évidemment pour la faire
perdurer
et là pour le coup on arrive vraiment en
la fin de la conférence
mais avant de terminer j'aimerais vous
inviter à une dernières explorations
intérieur je vous demander à tous de
prendre cinq secondes pour vous poser à
vous même la question qui suis-je
prenez 5 secondes pour vous poser cette
question qui suis-je
allez-y
si vous répondez à cette question alors
quoi que vous répondiez vous utiliserez
des mots pour vous définir vous
utiliserez donc une mémoire à commencer
par celle des mots vous me direz par
exemple je suis telle personne j'ai vécu
une telle chose
je m'appelle nicolas ou caroline robin
laetitia collège
vous me direz tout ça nous sommes
aujourd'hui à l'heure de l'information
et nous voyons passer de grandes
quantités d'informations par jour mais
comprendre
nous l'avons vu ne suffit pas à utiliser
toutes ces informations
c'est seulement lorsque nous pouvons
commencer à en parler avec nos propres
mots que l'information vient alors
doucement ceux liés à notre somme de
connaissances générales du monde et de
connaissances en connaissance c'est
toute notre identité qui se transforme
acquérir une nouvelle information est
donc très loin d'être un acte anodin car
c'est le début d'un nouveau changement
dans notre conception du monde et de
nous mêmes alors à vous qui venait
d'assister à cette conférence
re mémorable et qu'ils allaient bientôt
pouvoir l'art est expliqué avec vos
propres mots qui sait si votre nouvelle
métamorphose n'a pas bientôt commencer
merci à tous